the story of a devoted husband and wife
separated by evil forces and then
reunited
after overcoming great travails has
universal human appeal
but this theme has reached its literary
peak in the hindu tradition
widely recognized as the first major
work of sanskrit literature
the ramayana recounts the life of rama
the perfect prince and his faithful wife
sita
as she is abducted by a demon king and
then liberated
by her husband after a cosmic battle
emically many hindus today regard the
ramayana
as the divine rama's absolutely true
life history
in contrast for many outside or etic
readers this massive poem provides an
unmatched source
for understanding the extended history
of ancient indian society and culture
especially of the elite class of kings
and warriors who dominated
the emerging kingdoms of north india
from the 6th century bce
over the next nine centuries
in this lecture we'll start with an
examination of the nature of the
ramayana
as a premier example of cavea a leading
sanskrit poetic genre we'll note its
differences
and similarities with classical greek
and latin epics
and also with today's ideas about
history writing
as we briefly recount the narrative of
the life of its hero rama
we'll discuss what we as etic historians
can learn about the political
social and cultural world that the
ramayana
describes we'll end by looking at how
diverse
indian and southeast asian people have
used the ramayana over time
down to the present in its genre and
scope the ramayana is often compared by
western readers
with homer's odyssey and virgil's aeneid
each is a work of literature but each
also conveys the history
of a divinely descended man
homer's odysseus has as the ancestor
the greek messenger god hermes aeneas
virgil tell us tells us is the son of
the roman
goddess venus and rama according to many
tellers of his life
is an avatara or birth on earth
in human form of the god visnu
each of these massive poems also tells
us much about
their author's respect of cultural and
social worlds
although in differing ways
one repeated criticism by outsiders has
been that
unlike that of the west indian history
writing does not have any real
biographies
but the ramayana is the life story of
rama
in enoch terms rama is the god visnu
born on earth but he's still born as a
human
with human limitations and the life
story
further one main purpose of rama's birth
and of the ramayana
itself is to teach moral behavior dharma
to people many western biographers
also use their subject's life to teach
moral lessons
and many people read them in order to
find role models to emulate or
avoid so in this sense the life story of
rama
compares to the genre of biography
but since the rama of the ramayana was
in etic terms not a real person
many outsiders might not consider this
text a real
biography but rather the amalgamation of
some possible historical facts about one
or more princes
compiled over a long period of time
this text also reflects the larger
historical processes
of sanskrit-speaking north indians
spreading their influence
across the dravidian language speaking
south
the setting of the ramayana includes
some very real places
and social formations recall that from
about the sixth century bce onward
especially in the north indian gangetic
plain hundreds of locally based
janapadas or
people's places were developing into
small kingdoms
one of these kingdoms was gosala with
its capital at ayodhya
where the ramayana begins and ends
most of these kingdoms had a raja a king
who fought
or allied with his neighbors to expand
or just to survive
gradually kshatriya martial dharma or
code
for moral conduct became the model for
many of these competing
and collaborating kings and princes
first in north india
and then in parts of central and south
india as well
in most north indian hindu kingdoms some
brahmanas serve this royalty as advisors
priests teachers genealogists or bards
the ramayana may have begun as a bardic
epic
by a courtier about a noble prince of
ayodhya
beneath brahmanas and kashatrias and
ideally under their protection
were merchants peasants artisans and
other subjects
but they do not appear very often in the
ramayana except as attendance on the
royal court
or as subjects seeking redress of
grievances from the king
or as foot soldiers in their armies
so ramayana is mainly an elite text
primarily focused on rajas their
extended families
their supporters servants and enemies
both demonic
and human now emek and etic ideas about
the complex
authorship of the ramayana differ in
significant ways
based on different ways of knowing
history
a leading emec view credits the sage
valmiki
with composing the most authoritative
original
sanskrit telling of the ramayana
but the emec view also presents the
author differently
from how etic historians might
understand the role
either of an historian or a creative
writer
of literature in valmiki's own
telling he himself only participates as
a relatively
minor figure in the actual events of the
ramayana
valmiki was a reformed bandit who had
achieved great merit through becoming a
forest-dwelling ascetic
it is in his rustic hermitage where the
main figures
rama and his wife sita rest early in
their travels
toward the end of the ramayana sita
returns to take refuge in valmiki's
hermitage to give birth
and raise rama's and her twin sons
so as an eyewitness valmiki personally
participates
relatively little in the events
instead as the ramayana explains valmiki
hears
rama's whole story from the demigod
narada
and then is ordered by the creator god
brahma to retell it
valmiki also meditates deeply
and gains cosmic insights about what has
happened
learning things that he had not known
before
so in the emet tradition valmiki bases
his account on divine information and
guidance
not primarily on his being an eyewitness
finally valmiki teaches the ramayana to
rama's own sons who recite it for the
first time in public
to rama himself who would have corrected
any errors
if there had been any therefore in its
own emic terms
the truth of this story can't be doubted
but what did valmiki actually personally
create
here the emek tradition credits valmiki
with inventing the specific
32-syllable poetic meter called ashloka
in which the ramayana and various other
classical
sanskrit poems were recited but how did
valmiki come up with a shloka meter
in the ramayana valmiki himself explains
that he was observing
two birds in loving union just then a
forest dwelling human hunter perhaps
anadavasi
shot the male bird dead leaving the
female bird in mortal agony
valmiki spontaneously cursed the hunter
to wander eternally this curse was in
the shloka meter
and that was valmiki's original
contribution making him
the adikavi or first poet
many later authors composed their
sanskrit poetry
using the same shloka meter
but in edict terms valmiki could not
have been the sole author of the
ramayana
given its sheer volume and its many
centuries of composition
in the current form of the sanskrit
ramayana attributed to valmiki
the ramayana is 50 thousand lines long
which is double homer's odyssey and
virgilson need combined
further linguists and historians of
religion analyze the text as a product
of about 900 years
of adding to altering and editing by
many sequential authors
each of whom however gave valmiki credit
for the entire text
now let's turn to the emic life history
of rama as presented
in valmiki's ramayana given the great
length of this text we'll have to
concentrate
on the account of rama's life the main
subject and leave out
many of the vast numbers of episodes and
the myriad of branch stories interwoven
with it
king dasharata rules the north indian
kingdom of yoja
while both eric and emec scholars agree
that this was a real place
the center for an expanse of janapada
there's no
ethic evidence of this particular king
nonetheless although the emacly real
king dasharata rules virtuously
he has no male heirs so he hires brahman
priests to perform a great sacrifice
earning him much merit indeed out of the
sacrificial fire arises a vessel
filled with a special rice milk
each of his three queens consumes some
of it and each becomes pregnant with
sons
the middle queen takes two portions so
she has twin sons
while these events are taking place on
earth in heaven the hindu gods face a
major problem
a ten-headed demon named ravana himself
performed great austerities
and an awesome sacrifice which gained
him the power to demand from the gods
that he be made invincible against any
god
or demon but in his overweening pride
ravana does not ask to be invulnerable
against a human arrogantly
ravana then oppresses brahmanas
disrupting their religious rights and
threatening
the moral order of the universe
so the great god vishnu agrees to be
born in the world as human and thus
able to kill ravana visnu
therefore voluntarily descends to earth
taking birth as dhatarata's four sons
rama and his three brothers
simultaneously but mostly as rama
the son of the elder senior queen
as valmiki describes in much detail rama
grows up as a perfect prince always
following his kshatriya dharma
there are long passages wherever amiki
recounts how rama
selflessly defeats evil forces
especially
respecting and protecting forest
dwelling ascetics
he thus explicitly and implicitly models
the ideal behavior
for not just princes but for all hindus
to follow
when rama is ready to marry he enters a
swamp for
sita the princess of a neighboring
kingdom swayamvara
literally means that a woman chooses her
own husband
but the ramayana describes this as a
contest among suitors
whichever man is able to string a
massive bow
wins the bride only rama's great merit
enables him to win the contest
how then is this the wedding of the
bride's own
choosing well in emic terms the bride's
own
karma or merit determined who would win
in emec terms sita is a goddess lakshmi
that is
visnu's wife voluntarily born on earth
in order
to be rama's bride so this is the
inevitable outcome
of the contest in this
and many other episodes the ramayana
shows exactly how the system of karma
works
everything that happens is the
appropriate result
of the meritorious or de-meritorious
actions
of everyone involved in that action
while the details are in edit terms
superhuman
the evidence about bridal and other
contests among princes
and marriage alliances among kingdoms
fits with our other historical evidence
about that time period
eventually king dasarata decides to
abdicate and crown rama
as the new king but as rama's coronation
approaches
his youngest stepmother kaikai becomes
jealous and schemes to have her own son
bharata
made the next king by her meritorious
action
earlier in her life kaikai has earned
two promises owed to her
by king dasarata she uses the first boon
to get the reluctant dasarata to declare
bharata as his heir
and the second to send rama into exile
into the forest for 14 years
dasaratha then dies cursing kaiki for he
for her improper and selfish desire so
she herself gains no advantage
from her improper request
this moment of crisis enables valmiki
and the other authors of the sanskrit
ramayana
to illustrate further moral lessons
rama virtuously accepts his father's
order
however reluctantly given and that goes
that very day willingly into exile
his wife sita voluntarily goes with him
taking on the hardships of forest life
and thus showing how in enoch terms
an ideal wife should act
for his part the brother bharata refuses
to accept the throne
that his mother improperly obtained for
him
instead he governs in rama's name taking
on all the burdens of rule
with none of the benefits barta is after
all
vishnu on earth as well so he
illustrates how a younger brother should
act
respectfully toward his elder brother
one of their middle twin brothers
lakshmina
also goes with rama to serve him in the
forest while the other
twin chatrugana stays with bharata to
assist him
much of the lengthy ramayana recounts
the trials and virtues
of rama and sita in the forest as they
travel from ayodhya
south across india this is where the
epic describes great diversity of the
geography
and the societies of india throughout
rama exemplifies the proper dharmic
behavior
in a number of trying situations in one
a lustful sister of the demon king
ravana
named surprinka tries to seduce both
rama and his brother lakshmana
when rama declines her offer explaining
that he's already married to sita
sir peraka offers to kill her and take
sita's place
finally lakshmana disgraces surprise for
her
improper lust the pivotal point in the
ramayana comes when the demon king
ravana determines to carry off sita
ravana does this out of his lascivious
lust for her
and also to get revenge for his
mutilated sister
naka so the demons generally all act
with
excessive desire well that is their
dharma
they also receive punishments for acting
on it
in order to carry off sita ravana has
one of his demon courtiers take on the
form of a golden deer
who prances before sita and entices her
to desire it as a pet
for this sita herself begins to
accumulate
demerits at least according to the
prevailing emic interpretation
that make her vulnerable to being
carried off by ravana
sita urges rama to chase after the
golden deer
rama sets off after it as it keepers
just out of range
but rama does not accumulate demerit for
being deceived
by the disguised demon saying if it's a
deer there's no harm in hunting it
but if it's a demon then it's a dharma
to kill it anyway
he shoots and mortally wounds the dear
disguised
demon but in his dying breath
this demon cries out in rama's voice for
lakshmana's help
hearing this sita is again deceived into
doubting rama's prowess
and urges lakshmina to leave her and go
help rama
lakshmina refuses to leave sita
unguarded
but then she unjustly criticizes him and
lakshmana is thus forced
to go when ravana approaches
in the disguise of a brahmana mendican
sita is again deceived
about how to act in accordance with her
dharma she moves forward
to offer him food and thereby comes
under
ravana's power one emic lesson here
is that women even perfect women like
sita are susceptible to desire
and misperception of the true nature of
situations
but a seat is carried off all her
demerits are burned off as well
and thereafter in the ramayana sita
always acts in accordance with her
dharma
another result of this abduction is that
ravana's death is now assured
rama has the dharmic justification to
kill him
which was the prime purpose of vishnu
taking birth as rama in the
on earth in the first place
in order to perform his dharma by
recovering sita
rama recruits the local population of
monkeys and bears as his allies
most notable among these is hanuman a
divinely descended monkey who becomes
rama's leading servant
and a very popular deity in his own
right
hanuman is known for his strength and so
is worshipped by many wrestlers today
he's also the most faithful servant and
so an emec role model
for lower-born people rama's local
allies search
everywhere to no avail finally haneman
leaps across the water talanka
the kingdom of ravana today most hindus
believe that hanuman
crossed the narrow strait now called the
gulf of manor
between india and sri lanka island
there hanuman finds sita confined but
resistant
to ravana's enticements hanuman offers
to rescue her himself
but she insists that only rama should
liberate her
since that is his dharma as her husband
hanuman returns to rama with the news
but to invade
lanka rama and his allies have to build
a bridge
this bridge provides a good example of
how etic and emic evidence
coincide and yet also differ there is
indeed a shallow
underwater limestone ridge over the 20
miles between south india
and sri lanka this ridge is clearly
visible from satellite photographs
for edec geologists the underwater ridge
has natural causes
and needs no sacred source
in emec terms however this bridge was
constructed by hanuman
and as allied bears and monkeys using
the power of rama's name
to make it secure although later storms
sank part of his bridge
underwater for many devotees of rama
these satellite photographs are
scientific
evidence for the truth of the ramayana
although that sacred text
needs no external proof
in the great war between rama's forces
and ravana's demon armies
many battles and perils are detailed
each with a moral lesson attached
for instance at one point lakshmana is
gravely wounded
and about to be carried off by the
exultant demons
but lakshmi remembers that he is vishnu
incarnate and therefore
invulnerable at the same time however
lakshna must be human or he cannot aid
in the killing of ravana
to revive lakshmina hanaman is sent off
to a distant mountain to bring back a
special
healing herb on his arrival there he
realizes he isn't educated enough to
identify the needed
medicinal plant so he cleverly brings
back the entire mountain
enabling the physicians at lakshman
aside to select the herb and cure him
this emily shows how even uneducated
servants
can cleverly use their brute strength in
devoted service
to their elite masters
finally rama kills ravana and liberates
sita
when she rushes to rejoin rama however
he repudiates her as having been
impure by living under ravana's power
for some emek commentators this shows
that rama only acted out of moral duty
not his personal desire for zita
other analysts in india and the west
critique rama for blaming the victim
sita for her unwilling abduction
just as so many abducted women have been
blamed by their family and by society
in so many cultures valmiki has sita
then
enter a sacred fire to prove her purity
to the world
only then does rama accept her back to
explain his action
rama proclaims that he knew all along
that she was pure
but since less enlightened people might
not understand that
he had to demonstrate her purity to them
by this fiery test
after the return of rama and sita to a
yoja they rule as king and queen
completely virtuously even today the
phrase
rama raja or rama's reign conveys
for many orthodox hindus a period of
perfect governance
that present-day politicians should
imitate
but once again the unenlightened
subjects of a yoja misperceive dharma
and begin to ignorantly
question sita's virtue
so rama feels he must send sita away
banishing her to valmiki's hermitage
unaware
that she is pregnant with his two sons
as use these sons come to rama's court
and recite thoramayana
which valmiki has taught them then sita
returns to her mother earth
becoming her divine form of lakshmi
again
finally rama too ends his earthly life
and again becomes the god vishnu in
edict terms
rama may have been a real prince or
several princes
whom local people deified and then
brahmanas later sanskritized
into the vedic god visnu as one of his
incarnations
in emec terms rama is a beloved deity to
whom people can relate
often more accessibly revered than a
more distant visnu
as filled as a ramayana is with moral
lessons
brand stories and numerous episodes it
is also a biography of rama
to many hindus today every word of
al-miki's telling
is absolute truth but for many others
hindus and non-hindus the story of rama
could be used for other purposes
after valmiki many other authors retold
the story of rama in slightly or greatly
different
ways each region of india has one or
more tellings of rama's story
in its own language for example cumben
in the early 13th century retold the
story in tamil
a prominent dravidian language of
southeast india
today there are over 75 million speakers
of tamil
more than the number of people who speak
italian for example
etamil is only one of india's many
regional languages
each of these later authors using his or
her own language
highlights different features of rama's
story
removing episodes present in valmiki's
telling
adding others and thus changing the
epic's length
content and purpose the 16th century
mughal emperor akbar whom we'll discuss
in a later
lecture had his muslim officials
supervise the translation of the
ramayana
into the persian language of his
imperial court as a major work of both
history
and also moral teaching
many devotional films for example in the
popular bollywood and various regional
cinema styles have used parts of the
ramayana
as their plot in recent years various
television producers
have used that medium to present the
story of rama
the most famous of these hindi language
television programs
were produced and directed by ramanand
sagar and his production company
he based his telling both on valmiki and
also on the 16th century tulsidas
the most famous of the retellers of
rama's story in hindi
initially there were 78 episodes
broadcast one
each sunday morning in 1987 88
on the government's official network
soccer's team then repeatedly remade
these
for broadcast on other networks over the
next 30 years
many spin-offs sequels and other
versions
have also been broadcast
there have also been many translations
and retellings in english
most recently from valmiki sanskrit
telling
under the general editorship of american
scholars
robert and sally goldman but critics
of the brahmanic system of arnaz and
dharma have also used the story of rama
to prove a very different history for
example
there is a substantial jati or birth
group that proudly calls itself the
descendants
and followers of valmiki although elite
hindus used to class them as untouchable
before untouchability became illegal in
today's india
so various communities have challenged
their low status
in the brahmonic system by using the
prestige of
thoraminum
over the last few centuries many fiction
writers have also used
episodes or characters from the ramayana
to convey a variety of messages
that clash with those of valmiki's
tellings
feminist short story authors and
playwrights celebrate sita
often portraying her as a strong
independent woman
wronged by an insensitive husband
some social reformers have critiqued
valmiki's
and tulsidas's orthodox tellings of the
life of rama
claiming those elite authors justify his
abuses
of his lower class and lower varna
subjects
most prominently a culturalist
nationalist movement
in the tamil speaking region of south
india called the dravidian organization
or dk movement
started in the 1930s to attack brahman
domination
although brahmanas were a relatively
small minority
in the tamil region they controlled much
of the political
and economic power there under the
charismatic
eevee ramasamy known as evr
this dravidian movement pronounced the
ramayana to be the history
of an unjust invasion by north indians
according to evr valmiki describes the
inhabitants of south india as merely
monkeys and bears
and the inhabitants of sri lanka as
demons
evr argued in print and dramatized in
the streets of that
tamil speakers and other southerners
must discredit
the brahmanic religious system that
treated them as
sub-human until they did that they would
remain
mentally under the north indian
brahmanic cultural hegemony or
domination
therefore evr mounted massive public
processions
in which images of rama were beaten with
defiling shoes
and pictures of him burnt to show the
contempt the tamils
should have for rama and brahmanism
out of this tamil cultural movement came
the political parties that have
dominated the government
in tamilnadu state for many decades
the narrative and sacred power of the
ramayana has meant that it spread beyond
india
to southeast asia especially in
indonesia cambodia
thailand and burma now myanmar
in indonesia an account of rama in old
javanese dates from about 870.
one of java's most popular shadow puppet
plays
also features the story of rama
cambodia's famous 12th century angkor
wat temple
has many stone carved panels and statues
illustrating the ramayana then around
1350
the king of thailand renamed his capital
ayutya
after rama's capital ayoja
from the 18th century a burmese version
of the ramayana became the burmese
national epic
so we'll as we'll see for buddhism and
islam hindu cultural influences spread
from india far to the east but as rama's
story moved
local cultures adapted it to their own
cultural values and artistic forms
although their attitudes toward the
story of rama their methodologies and
their conclusions often differ
both emic and ethic readers can learn
much
about the ancient indian history from
ramayana
in the next couple of lectures we'll
discuss in similar ways the other
major indian epic the mahabharata and
its account of ancient
indian history
[Music]
you